my guest tonight has been a cast member
on saturday night live for
18 seasons that's incredible the longest
in history
his new nbc series keenan airs tuesdays
at 8 30 on nbc please welcome our good
friend kenan
thompson keenan how are you
please sit everyone's calm down
everybody relax
i'm just i'm just you know what please
sit right are going we're losing it for
you
in here i've got i've got 180 cardboard
cutouts just losing your [ __ ]
you're here however hello cardboard cut
out lovers please
relax i'm great man how are you doing
i'm doing
well uh congratulations you just hosted
nickelodeon kids choice awards
saturday night and one of the highest
honors
in our culture higher than i think
any other award a peabody an oscar
is to get slimed and you got slimed
look at that come on that that's nothing
in comparison to how
the rest of it went that was the
beginning of it that was after the first
flash there were about
10 splashes after that let me ask you a
question what is that stuff
because they're now looking into it i
think it's toxic
i really do well i hope not because i
was just
i was just covered in it so i'm curious
like
you have been you know some people host
the nickelodeon awards and they're kind
of part of that world
you really started in that world i mean
how old were you
when you were doing your first show you
were you were a kid
yeah i was like 15 you know 14 15.
when you were when you were doing when
you were doing keenan and cal you were
14 15 years old yeah all that started
first and then the keenan and kel show
came like
the following year so like 15 yeah 14
15 yeah now i was curious like i was
so much older than that before anybody
recognized me
you know i was 30 i think when i first
started
on camera and people were like hey i
know you
that's got to be pretty intense when
you're that age
such a young age still forming as a
human being
and suddenly you're dealing with fame
what was that like
it was a slower journey than you would
imagine
because you know nickelodeon was pretty
much still just
a cable channel basically and those who
had cable
you know you still had to be a kid so it
wasn't like i was running into a lot of
kids unless i went to like
chuck e cheese or something like there
was a year or two where i couldn't go to
chuck e cheese and i was like
all right you know i'm i'm pretty
popular like you know i'm doing doing
pretty good
out there stay away from those uh chuck
e cheese's out there yeah
i've been asked i've been asked not to
go to chuck e cheese but for a different
reason yeah i was going to say it might
be a
different list we'll talk about that
later um
i don't know if we will but
[Laughter]
those are false charges keenan yeah sure
[Laughter]
of course to decide is this true that
when you are starting out you you
wanted to get recognized really badly so
you went someplace to try and get
recognized
yeah i was i was gonna stay like i
remember there was a very specific day
in my memory that me and kell like got
up
we were like let's go to the mall man
and see if anybody will recognize us you
know because we've been putting in work
for
one season on each show but i was new to
television and stuff like that so i
thought it was
an immediate type of thing like yeah
we've done a season of television so
people should recognize and give up some
high fives and uh we stood in the middle
of the mall
for about an hour i'd say just kind of
watching people go back and forth
and then grabbed and orange julius i
think and kind of just left
and right so you stood there looking
around just
waiting for people to come up to you and
they didn't come up to you
they did not not a one no one asked if
we were okay
no one asked if we were looking for
something you know
we couldn't have been more suspicious
but nobody even
thought we were a threat at all um and
it was a long quiet
ride back to the apartment it was just
like so that didn't work exactly
well fortunately uh that would not
happen now but um you know i think it's
actually healthier for you
to have it be a little bit of a slow
build you know what i mean
if it had been keenan mania right away
uh god knows where you'd be right now
this is a better way
building it slowly i think so i mean if
you look at the numbers you know the
majority of people that you know
catch the fire really really quickly you
know it you know burns them out you know
the flame get too close to the flame i
got too close to the
flame 93-94 and then i was never seen
again
[Laughter]
um hey i want to ask you about you were
doing sketch comedy at that same age so
you're in kind of a sitcom world kind of
but you're also in a in a
doing full-on sketch comedy and playing
characters so
i think i was thinking about this today
of all the people i know that have been
on saturday live and i've known so many
of them
you've been on the longest on sunday
live but also
you probably had the most years of
sketch comedy experience before
you even got the show of anybody i know
yeah i mean that's interesting i mean it
was like
five seasons of all that so
yeah we looked at it i mean we used to
call ourselves like the snl for kids and
stuff like that but
thought we would ever really make it you
know even to like auditioning for it for
real for real just because
you know it just seemed very you know
it's just such a different world like we
were in florida and then we went to la
you know what i mean so i didn't have
that like new york chicago
comedy scene hustle knowing that sml is
that 30 rock like i didn't know
what 30 rock was you know until i went
there for an audition basically so
it was very far-fetched kind of idea for
all of us pretty much and then you know
as i stayed kind of diligent
pressing the issue of letting me
audition or whatever i finally got the
chance
and then yeah i don't know if i'll ever
give that job up you know
yeah yeah well i don't see a reason why
i think there used to be this feeling
like well i've done sign out live and
now i need to move on and and and and
put that down and do something else and
it's occurred to me that
the world we live in now that's not
really necessary
you can do sarnot live you can do it
if you had to part of the time do your
sitcom
make a movie it's not an either or world
anymore so and you're so great on that
show i just don't see why there's any
reason to say well
your time's up you've got to leave high
school it's not that way anymore
thank you for saying that i mean that's
exactly how i see it too you know
like it was a time like you said it was
a platforming type of situation but
for me it was always kind of different
because i came into the show with people
knowing who i was and wanted to see me
mature or whatever and now i'm at to the
point where
a lot of people don't really know the
show without me being on it you know so
it's
like a weird kind of
do i want to leave and just go do
whatever else
without it like not really you know i
think it's a very special place it's a
very special
tool to keep sharp you know just being
on top of things week after week and
well there's
yeah there's a there's a type of comedy
that you can do on saturday live that
you can't do other places i remember
when i was there
phil hartman one of the great sketch
performers of all time he was on the
show and then
he had been there what at the time
seemed like a long time and then
he was said well i guess i need to move
on now and do my other stuff
and i thought no show is going to use
phil hartman as well as sarnath live
they're going to show and and he went on
to do other things and then
sadly uh you know uh was gone but
um very like one at a time yeah you know
years in between uh incredible phil
hartman performance you know just
because
weight on the project basically exactly
you're in the hands of other people
whereas on starting out live there's so
much you can do
and which brings up the question of
lorne
lauren michael's obviously a famous
uh creator producer starting out live uh
huge influence on me um pretty much gave
me my career
so i'm indebted to him like so many of
us are
he produces uh he produces keenan he
produces your
show and i'm wondering is he
in i i know lauren from the world of uh
being my producer on saturday live and
being the producer on
my late night show what's he like on a
sitcom is he still the same guy
that kind of doesn't say much but when
he says something it cuts like a knife
oh man it cuts like a machete
it's like you do so you know like
there's a lot
on the line as it is like the show is
you know self-titled at this point
you know it was giving larry at one
point which i felt
much more you know distant from
and you know like just an actor coming
to do a show but now this is called
keenan
you know what i mean it's all about me
and like you know the phrase you said
keenan
lauren produces keenan like that's kind
of like really the overall
kind of statement for my life for the
last 18 years he's just been that guy so
yeah
the fact that there's so much weighing
on it and we do so much thinking and
back and forth and before he chimes in
when he does chime in and it's something
we haven't thought of it's like
[ __ ] man you know what i mean like why
aren't you just around
all the time but you know he can't be
everywhere
at all times but you know it's nice when
he does chime in because he's usually
pretty on point
yeah he can sort of uh just put his
he can shine a light on something and
and you realize immediately
oh okay yeah link i'm sure he's watched
you know watch his rehearsals of your
show and if there's something that
doesn't seem right
he'll say to you like he he used to say
to me that my manners were very
important you have good manners and i
thought
what does that matter it's about it's
about being funny and he would say no
it's funny is one thing but you have to
have this other component which is part
of you which is to be nice to people and
to be well mannered and
uh that was impressive he has a way of
making it feel
a lot less cooler than you think it is
but
your approach to how you present that
cool is
pinnacle and that's what he makes kind
of like
lock in on it's like you want to be nice
and you want people to like you
yes lean into that lean into the night
lean keen and lean into the nice
i didn't realize it had a different
title i thought there was a show called
uh
keenan and you auditioned for it and you
got it and yeah
[Laughter]
we had keane and ivory wayans in mind
who the [ __ ]
is this guy um uh
you know what i love about your show is
uh
first of all i really enjoy you and i
think you're a terrific performer and
then you've got don
johnson doing this with you who one of
the coolest people
in my opinion in the history of
television
and then uh the times that i've briefly
gotten to chat with him
he's such a nice guy don johnson
absolutely it's weird you know because
when i was growing up it was like him
stingray
and mr t yes one of the coolest people
on television you know
yeah like stingray and hawk you know
that was my like crocodile tubs you know
right for like
right after that and then mr t was just
the epic so
when i got a chance to facetime him and
within five seconds he was just
as chill as any dude could be and he was
just like i love the idea for the show
and blah blah blah and we talked about
like fatherhood and loud you know it's
just
an immediate bond i was like oh this guy
is the greatest
then once i started making him laugh and
figured out what his funny bone was
and let him tell stories and jokes and
stuff like that that make him laugh as
well it was just like
secreted in cement like that guy has one
of the greatest laughs
in the world does he ever tell stories
about miami vice
or is he yes yes
every day and it came up the other day
that he knew some pretty
intriguing drug lords over the years oh
yeah because he was in
miami uh i mean in the 80s and that was
the most popular show in the world so
don johnson's probably meeting some
pretty interesting characters
yeah he's got some great stories and i'm
glad he's on the other side of it now
in his later years and he can just relax
and tell these stories but
man they are wild yeah
uh how's your life going you're you've
got
young kids how you've got daughters how
old are they
my babies uh georgia six and gianna is
two and my wife christina she's a grown
woman
so i'm glad we got that straightened out
your uh your your older guy your
six-year-old
she must know what you do does she have
the performing gene does she want to be
be doing what you're doing she is the
biggest ham
i've ever seen she is already like
recording videos in the house and like
sending them to family members
and just like has a whole show going so
she definitely
has the itch and yeah i want to like
put her in theater classes or something
when she gets ready but
right now it's a very like little kid
kind of playing in the mirror type of
thing or whatever but it's
it's pretty extravagant like she's doing
full-on like shows because i guess she
watches a lot of youtube kids things
yeah she's gonna be posting stuff on
youtube and then going to the mall
to try and get recognized yeah then you
know you've got a problem
that's when i know it's like was that an
orange julius did you go to the mall
uh is it um you know i just want to
mention keenan before i go which really
impresses me is that you guys
are making this and been have been
making it during
covid and so um i mean
i know a bunch of productions have been
doing that
but i think it's it's one thing for
dramas to pull that off
i just think comedy is such a hard thing
to do
in the covid world and you guys have
pulled it off so my hat's off to you but
it's got to be difficult
to get into that rhythm and click when
everyone's wearing a hazmat suit and
distancing and it definitely is and
that's where i have to
again give it up to my cast mates you
know don johnson
chris red yep my little daughters danny
and dana you know fortune feemster
taylor louderman
you know kimberly lewis like everybody
that's been working on this
jeff i can never remember my man's
jeff's last name but he's
insanely funny on the show he's like the
auxiliary like weatherman kind of
character
at the new position crazy funny um
but yeah everybody is number one
professional and number two like
you know down to play basically and
we did it you know in a restricted kind
of a manner but
we got through it and you know once you
know we get those restrictions off of us
[ __ ] like stuff might get crazy
you know never swear again do you
understand i apologize
this isn't right excuse me ken this is
not uh nickelodeon uh you can't just be
throwing words around like that
no you cannot and once again that that's
my bad
so
[Laughter]
um well uh kenan airs i want to make
sure i get the word out keenan airs
tuesdays
at 8 30 p.m on nbc
and uh i'm uh just always i really enjoy
talking to you and i really love your
work you're doing a great job
you really are you're one of those young
young people that gives me hope
and i know someday we are going to take
that bicycle ride together
it's going to happen it's going to
happen you're saying it i know that you
don't think it's going to happen
i'm going to show you that los angeles
extends past the airport that's not
where mexico starts
and it's going to be a good ride i was
certain i was in mexico
i get it he's inconfusable
yeah people if you want to know what
we're talking about check out my podcast
with keenan which uh you were absolutely
hilarious and we had a blast
um check that out we need to have you on
my podcast
everybody's doing podcasts oh yeah i
know podcast now is like jury duty
you've got it you've got to have a
podcast once at least every two years
it's like a box you check you've got to
do it absolutely
yeah so please please come check i'm
kidding i'm there anytime
hey keenan thank you so much take care i
know you're working hard but try and
rest
up and say hey everybody at sign out
live explain who i am
i i will so he's a very kindly nice
older
white woman
[Laughter]
it's a great story how he turned into a
white woman yeah
it happened when i was 15. all right
i'll talk to you later keenan take care
incredible all right thank you man